Hey it's me Destin welcome back to Smarter Every Day. So we're in my daughter's bathroom?
I have been informed that there is a spider that ah,
well I'm the dad. It's what I do. I slay spiders.
And so before I destroy him in a fantastic way,
however I choose to do that, I'm going to use
these macro tubes on this camera to see if we can get some
close-up of a brown recluse. So anyway
this should be interesting. So here he is.
Let's put one more tube on here. Brown recluses have six
eyes instead of eight like spiders normally do. They're venomous
so they inject venom into the body. Most people say poisonous but it's actually venomous.
When brown recluses come in contact with people they only bite
about 50% of the people, they're not very aggressive. But, one other fact
that's interesting is that when they come in contact with daddies,
that have little girls, they die by fire
100% of the time. I wonder if that's the web?
making material that just blew out the side?
Whatever. It's dead, and it won't hurt my girl.
OK now that seemed a little bit cruel but I don't normally mess around when it comes to my kids. Now before you complain
in the comments, the reason I didn't kill him immediately is I wanted people who live in this area
which is where brown recluse spiders live, I wanted them to know exactly what
they look like. You're looking for that upside down fiddle on their back.
Those are the spiders that have hemotoxins in their venom and will hurt you
really bad. These things can live for months without eating or drinking. They hide in
bedsheets and you get em out of your closet, not even thinking about it. Put em on your bed
and they bite you and before you know it you've got pieces of your body rotting off.
I don't always kill spiders, but when I do I try to do it with fire. Anyway, I'm Destin,
you're getting Smarter Every Day. Just kill em with fire, just do that for me. Have a good one.
Going back to the amazon next. Later.
[music]
It's a scorpion without a tail.
- Oh man.
That is the ugliest beast I've ever seen.
[ Captions by Andrew Jackson ]
captionsbyandrew.wordpress.com
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.